alpha alpha males are not roots
in non-human primates and in human
primates
where the systems are functional uh
there may be other males who are brutes
but it's not the alpha alphas use
affiliative behaviors and conciliatory
behaviors and cooperation
uh to to accrue loyalty
which then is a way of of maintaining
power
and you know that's that's only sort of
in male hierarchy space and of course
you know what's
what i think one of the modern problems
that we are experiencing
is male hierarchies and female
hierarchies
both exist they follow different rules
there are different rules of engagement
it's a very rare species that actually
has both because typically
in other species one or the other sex
disperses and you don't
and and you also don't have multiple
males and multiple females in a group
together baboons being an interesting
exception to that but for us we've
combined you know we we now live in this
attempting to be egalitarian world where
we've got
this you know call it six million years
since we split with the ancestors of
bonobos and chimps
six million years of evolution within
our particular lineage
in which we've got female hierarchical
relationships and male hierarchical
relationships and now
i don't know post-industrial something
since at least agriculture
so at the at a minute at a maximum ten
thousand years old
we're combining these two hierarchies
and we're pretending it's just gonna be
easy and fine
and we have to figure it out like we
have to figure out how to work together
but uh imagining that we're just going
to default into male style of hierarchy
and it's going to be cool with all the
women or that we're going to just
default into female style of hierarchy
and it's going to be cool with all the
men is an amazing error and in fact what
i feel like we see is this like pendulum
swing from well
we were just doing it the male way
because women came into sort of the
external realizations of power later
and that wasn't really working for
everyone and at the moment we're seeing
this pendulum swing over into
really female styles of dominance
relationship
and it's equally dysfunctional it's just
something we don't have as much history
with recognizing
but that doesn't make it any better you
know this yeah
no the future is all of us
[Music]